i don't think we're past the point of no
return yet
but if the kids who are in first grade
now graduate from 12th grade before we
fix the problem then i think we lose an
entire generation and i don't think we
have a generation left before the
existence of not only america but but
sort of the western liberal democracy
and western liberal edifice as we know
it is brittle enough to withstand the
loss of an entire generation in between
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
biotech entrepreneur and the author of
working vivek ramaswamy welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me guys
it's great to have you on the show uh
before we get into your brilliant book
which we both really enjoyed tell
everybody uh who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
through life that brings you to be here
sitting talking to us
yeah sure so i tell a bit of it in the
book but uh the long story short is that
i was born and raised in cincinnati ohio
about an hour and a half drive from
where i am today in columbus ohio in the
middle of the midwest my parents were
immigrants from india they came over in
the late 1970s and early 1980s my dad
and my mom respectively they didn't have
a ton of money but they did come for an
education in this country and raised us
with uh values that i would say put
education first and so fast forward you
know 18 years later i was a student at
harvard studied molecular biology
graduated near the top of my class i was
a nerdy science guy for much of college
after i graduated i got into the world
of biotech investing at a hedge fund in
new york city in the fall of 2007 right
before the 08 financial crisis which
i'll tell you impacted a lot of my views
on capitalism the relationship between
capitalism and politics and in many ways
that are reflected in the book that i
wrote in any case i stayed at that firm
for seven years as an investor
three of those years i spent
simultaneously in law school at yale i
actually had an itch to study law and
public policy and political philosophy
that had never fully scratched as a
science guy so i did that from 2010 to
2013. i never practiced law i didn't
intend to probably the most tangible
thing about it was i met my wife who was
my next-door neighbor there she was a
med student and so that was you know it
was decidedly the most productive thing
that came out of law school although
there were three fun years
and then when i came back to new york
city i actually had a lot of spare time
on my hands because i had been managing
a portfolio for a hedge fund while going
to law school at the same time this was
something that uh you know left a busy
schedule in its wake but now i had the
entire law school block open so i
briefly tried my hand at stand-up comedy
actually in new york i mentioned that
since i know your guys's background i
wasn't as successful at comedian as you
guys are i that is to say i was you
haven't seen our material mate
well i was i was uh decidedly mediocre
probably did fewer than 10 shows uh and
and decided that it was time to hang the
jersey which i did but i learned a few
things in the process one of them was a
habit i created of writing down anytime
something annoyed me and it was a habit
that led me to a mediocre stand-up
comedy career but actually a much better
career as an entrepreneur i kept notes
every time something that i saw in the
biotech or pharma industry that really
annoyed me as an investor and eventually
that list got long enough that i decided
to leave my career as an investor and
start a biopharmaceutical company in
2014. so that's what i did i started roy
event sciences it was a heck of a
journey i've built the company from
scratch and there's now you know many
employees around the world it's a
company that's gotten a number of
medicines through the development
process a couple of which are fda
approved medicines today the one i'm
probably most proud of is an fda
approved drug for prostate cancer
but that being said i uh stepped down
from my role as ceo earlier this year
to work on a different kind of cancer
not a biological cancer but what i see
as a cultural cancer that was really
infecting every major institution that i
had seen or been a part of in in
corporate america in academic america
and beyond
and you know as you probably gathered
from my story i wasn't born into elite
america
but i have lived in elite america for
the last 15 years and i felt some sense
of responsibility
to speak with candor from the inside to
really put a spotlight on what i saw as
the defining scam of our time that the
american people and i think people in
democracies around the world really
needed to see for what it was and that
was something that i described in the
book as a sort of magic trick where a
lot of my peers pretend like they care
about something other than profit and
power precisely to gain more of each and
i'm sorry to say it's actually working
out pretty well for them i'm not sure
it's working out for civilized society
and for democratic societies around the
world and i hope the book that i wrote
is uh you know offers a little bit of a
path towards a better a better way
forward that i lay out in the book well
indeed and the issues that you talk
about is something we've covered on the
show quite extensively but one of the
things we haven't really got into is the
the very subject of your book which is
corporate america corporate britain etc
and what we wanted to talk to you about
is one of the strands of what we wanted
to talk about was this very thing i
think 10 15 years ago we all thought of
the ceo our image of a ceo if you had to
stereotype it would be mr burns from the
simpsons right this guy who didn't care
about anything except money who would
happily dump toxic waste in your in his
own water supply if it meant making a
buck etc and yet we are now here 2021 in
in an environment where the ceos are the
ones who are social justice donating
money to blm uh
lecturing the public about masculinity
all of this stuff how did that happen
vivek
yeah so look there's uh an age-old adage
of once you get to the destination you
want to get to you build a wall right
behind you so somebody else can't get
there too i think there's a bit of that
going on here but i think the essence of
what happens actually is what i describe
in the book it begins with the 2008
financial crisis i alluded it to it
before i had a front row seat i worked
at a hedge fund that was one of the few
firms named in in michael lewis's book
the big short i saw this play out and i
watched the aftermath of it as well i
lived in new york city at the time
and i think what happened is in the wake
of the 08 financial crisis you had to
occupy wall street movement you had a
movement that was skeptical of corporate
power and capitalism in america and what
the old left wanted to do was to take
money from those wealthy corporations
and redistribute it to poor people for
the benefit of poor people agree or not
that's what the old left wanted to do
but there was this new left a new breed
of the left that was born right around
the same time barack obama had been
elected as the first black president of
the united states there was a lot of
discussion about diversity and the
appearance of diversity in many of our
institutions
and what corporate america realized is
that actually they could go from being
the bad guys to being the good guys
if they just said the right things about
this new left movement the new woke left
movement so that's when you had big
banks and other big businesses start to
applaud diversity and inclusion start to
put token minorities on their boards and
on their committees started to muse
about the racially disparate impact of
climate change after flying on a private
jet to davos and so this actually ended
up being a pretty good trade where they
could actually be the good guys they
were happy to lend their money their
legitimacy to this new woke movement
but they didn't quite do it for free you
see what they expected in return is that
the new left would look the other way
when it came to leaving their corporate
power intact and i'm sorry to say it's
actually worked out masterfully for both
sides where you had a bunch of big banks
get in bed with a bunch of woke
millennials together they birthed well
capitalism
and they put occupy wall street up for
adoption and that game worked so well
that silicon valley did the same thing
censor content that the woke left
doesn't want to see online in return the
new democratic party looks the other way
when it comes to leaving our monopoly
power intact and again it works out
masterfully for both sides so the rest
of corporate america follows suit and so
in some sense it's a cynical arrangement
it's an arranged marriage it's not a
marriage of love it is more like mutual
prostitution
and the net result was the birth of this
new woke industrial complex that was far
more powerful than either big government
or big business alone because it was a
hybrid of the two that could do what
either of those couldn't do on its own
and i think that's the
that's the real force i think the real
threat to liberty and prosperity today
more so than big government is this new
woke industrial complex and that's a big
part of what i discuss in the book
and in the book you actually compared it
to a magic trick we've touched on that
would you manage to break it break it
down please because it comes in three
parts and i found that that idea
particularly compelling
well look i think i think there's i draw
from christopher nolan's movie the
prestige by the way christopher nolan
one of the great movie makers of all
time
actually uh produced probably the most
woke movie i've ever seen in my life
which is a recent movie produced during
the pandemic called tennant i don't mean
that disparagingly i actually mean it
mostly as a compliment for its artistic
merit in
laying woke ideology out on the table in
the form of a movie that's actually
really complicated after watching a
couple times at least i did in order to
understand even what was going on in
terms of the plot but once you piece it
together there's a really woke premise
at the heart of that movie so i offer
that as an aside well hold on i i watch
that movie what's the work premise of
the movie i'm curious
well you know you you know there's your
travel backwards and forwards through
time right it's sort of summarized at
the very end of the movie
where there's there's sort of the white
anti-hero and sort of the black hero
that are crossing paths and one of them
is the white guy's the one traveling
backwards in time and the black hero is
the one who's traveling forward in time
and he looks back and says why aren't
you coming with me and and the white
engineer looks back and he's a good guy
too but sort of looks back and says hey
i'm going that way you're going that way
and it was just an encapsulated moment
of the the velocity of time in terms of
where the different racial identities of
the white man going in one direction and
and sort of the black here are going in
the other direction that yeah i think i
think typified and captured part of the
message of what the anti-racist movement
is all about what the woke ideology is
all about is being conscious to the
historical power structures that may
have held one class of people back and
what they must do in terms of bearing
their obligation to send that class of
that disempowered class forward and i
thought he captured the moment in a
physics-laden time-twisted plot in a way
that only christopher nolan can but if
you saw that movie i think you'll know
what i mean
now anyway i'm a big christopher nolan
fan and one of his movies that i also
quite enjoy is the prestige where again
he plays with notions of time as he
often does but at the beginning of the
prestige is a description of what a
magic act is all about and and there's
three parts to the act there's the
pledge the turn and the prestige the
pledge is where the magician shows you
something that you like something like a
bird or something that might something
like that might be an animal might be a
rabbit shows you pledges to you what the
trick is going to be all about the
second part of the act is the turn where
he makes that disappear
but no trick is complete until you bring
back that which you made disappear and
that's the prestige where you bring it
back and no magic trick is complete
without the prestige and what i talk
about is 21st century capitalism i break
it down you know in in larger ways than
than i want to go through and right now
in the short form you can read the book
you know i think i basically the pledge
is identifying a market where ordinary
people sell ordinary things the turn is
finding an arbitrage in that market and
arbitrage has the ability to buy it
something for one price and
instantaneously sell it for a higher
price in that same market that's the
turn but the real prestige is covering
up that entire act with what i call the
new brand of woke smoke blowing
progressive values to cover up steps
number one and two to pretend like you
care about something other than profit
and power as i said earlier precisely to
gain more of each and you know the best
version of the the pledge the turn and
the prestige that i described earlier
came in the form of what one of the u.s
mutual funds state street did in the
last couple of years where
they were actually
facing a lawsuit from their female
employees alleging that they didn't pay
the female employees at the firm as much
as they paid the male counterparts and
so state street did of course the
natural thing that you'd expect them to
do when faced with employees who claim
that they're not being paid equally as
their male counterparts they built a
statue for the women
iconic bull in in wall street new york
and they built a little statue of a
little girl who stands up to that bull
and at the placard at the bottom of the
statue said that she capital s h e she
makes a difference
turns out that she didn't just describe
fearless girl as the young girl in the
statue was known to to be it also
described the etf or the exchange traded
fund she which traded as a ticker on the
stock exchange which you could buy and
if you buy you know that's money managed
by state street that they charge a nice
fee for so it's actually another nice
little win for the marketing department
now to put a topping off flourish on all
of it
kristin visible the feminist who
authentically created fearless girl she
believed in female empowerment and
fempowerment on wall street she created
the stature she was so excited about it
that she made a couple extra copies of
the statue too this is what female
empowerment needed to be about and
fearless girl was the face of female
empowerment well guess what state street
sues kristin visible the statue's
creator for creating three unauthorized
reproductions of the statue that they
had commissioned because as i said
earlier it's not good enough to make the
money disappear
as they do when they commission the
statue in the first place they have to
bring it back and so they suit her for
making the unauthorized reproduction so
there's countless stories just like this
in the book it's just one of the first
ones that i happen to tell
early on in the introduction to the book
but uh but thought i would leave you
guys
with a sense for what the magic trick is
all about
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
what is the problem with work capitalism
and let's just go explore it a little
bit because there is an argument to say
hang on a minute look at one point the
all these organizations were stuffed
with rich white people from privileged
backgrounds isn't this just a much
needed correction and isn't it a good
thing that these corporations are
pushing this
yeah so look i think that there's a lot
of compelling arguments in favor of
stakeholder capitalism or the new woke
brand of vote capitalism which says that
companies are responsible not just to
their shareholders but to other societal
interests too sounds pretty benign on
its surface
milton friedman by the way uh didn't
love that model 50 years ago he thought
that was going to make businesses run
less efficiently and be less profitable
for their shareholders and that that was
going to economically leave everyone
worse off and reduce the size of the
economic pie he had some valid concerns
but i will tell you that that is not my
core concern
my core concern is the opposite is the
way in which corporate overreach
actually renders our democracy hollow in
the process by converting a one-person
one-vote system into a one dollar
one-vote system where the people who
wield the greatest power in the
marketplace of products then are
empowered to wield even disproportionate
power in the marketplace of ideas and
i'm fine living in a market where the
best products get voted to the top based
on the number of dollars that are
deployed in the market but i'm not fine
with the best ideas in the marketplace
of ideas getting voted to the top based
on the number of dollars that one
controls and what this new philosophy
effectively demands is that a small
group of investors and ceos
people like me get together in closed
door rooms and decide what's best for
society at large on matters ranging from
racial justice to climate change and i
think those questions ought to be
adjudicated in a democracy in the open
public square through free speech and
open debate without the distortions of
economic power tilting the scales on
that conversation and so to me
not to offend you guys on the other side
of the pond here but that might have
been a model for old world europe where
a small group of church leaders and
labor elites and business elites would
get in a room and decide what was right
for the rest of society at large but
that wasn't america and it wasn't modern
democracy even in britain or canada or
anywhere else in the in the western
democratic conflict or in india for that
matter too
democracy works according to the
principle that we decide as citizens
together what that common good is and we
have a commitment to live and abide by
the prop by the results of that process
and to me this is the most flagrant
violation of democracy of all when a
small group of capitalist elites get to
tell everybody else how they're supposed
to live their lives they can sell their
products they can get rich i'm fine with
that but they shouldn't be able to
exercise more moral power or normative
power than my neighbors here in ohio and
i think that that's a big part of what
i'm fighting for in the book is to
restore the integrity of democracy
defined as such
integrity of democracy you say but and
you mentioned in the book the hunter
biden scandal
where twitter
effectively suppressed that story oh
they did i mean i think i think there's
no doubt that twitter made a value
judgment that of course jack dorsey when
he's pressed in front of congress about
it says that oh that was a mistake every
time these guys are pressed on one of
their egregious forms of overreach they
claim that it was a mistake in
retrospect but the damage is already
done you now have these social media
companies today
that are able to do what no company in
human history has been able to do which
is to control the acceptable bounds of
what can and cannot be discussed and
what once you affect what can't be
discussed you affect what can't even
occur in one's own thoughts and i think
that's the most dangerous kind of
corporate power of all
where america had its founding
didn't want to see the dutch east india
company reborn here in the united states
that was a company in europe that as you
all well know wielded not just market
power but wielded state-like power they
had their own militia they had their own
currency think of facebook's
cryptocurrency ambitions today they had
their own hospitals their own charitable
institutions they were like a quasi
state and the american system was born
on the idea that we did not want
corporate-like states
we had a constitutional democracy a
constitutional republic that ultimately
served as our state we didn't want to
create a corporatocracy in its wake and
so that's why we created even though we
created powerful corporations through
benefits like limited liability and
other concepts that the state created to
allow corporate shareholders to have a
lot of special advantages we said that
in return for that we want you to stay
in your lane we demand that the
directors of a corporation owe a
fiduciary duty only to shareholders not
just to protect those shareholders as
milton friedman might have surmised but
to protect the rest of society from
corporate overreach that was that was
the vision for the limited form of
corporate power and what we see today in
silicon valley is a perversion of that
where we have now the modern dutch east
india company on steroids that control
not only power in the market but the
power to determine what each of us can
and cannot discuss in the modern public
squares i think that's something that
represents one of the two great threats
to western idealism as we know it i
think china is at the top of the list
but i put the growing power of big tech
at number two on that list and that's a
big part of i discuss both extensively
in the book but i think it's a big part
of what i think can be fixed if if you
know the citizens in everyday
democracies around the world begin to
see what's going on with clear eyes well
vivek we'll come back to china in a
second but i wanted to go back a little
bit and talk about how this has all
happened because i'm not sure that i'm
necessarily persuaded that this is
uh these kind of ceos you know
skillfully manipulating the situation
like i'll give you an example i was i
was talking to uh an executive in the
publishing industry one of the biggest
publishers in the world and i was asking
him about the situation with freedom of
expression in publishing wokeness and he
said that one of the biggest challenges
for him was actually dealing with
younger employees because he himself has
a commitment to publishing people across
the political spectrum with different
opinions but he said to me imagine if
you were trigonometry if your cameraman
came up to you and was like you know
what i don't agree with having vivek on
the show and i think we need to have a
three-hour meeting to thrash out the
details of my disagreement uh and you
know he's tougher than both of those
well we'd have to agree yeah even so at
trigonometry that would never happen but
but in a big corporation somehow these
these older uh kind of experienced
higher status cos they're now feeling
like they have to for some reason
answer to a 20 year old and we saw
ourselves in the comedy industry when
francis used to work in a comedy club
you know you'd see people in the early
20s coming in and their expectation of
what as a junior person in an
organization you're entitled to
say to want to control to want to
influence like but by our standards and
we're sort of very very early
millennials are just off the charts
entitlements but but that's how those
people think so is it not a case of this
is actually democracy in action younger
people coming through and imposing the
the moral standards on old bigots like
me you and francis
so i don't think it's democracy in
action that's for sure but but i do
think that you have a point
that of course that's why it took a
whole book to expose that there's a lot
of nuances to this and it's not a
one-size-fits-all bill i think in some
cases it is a purely cynical top-down
phenomenon driven by
a lot of executives on wall street and
powerful big business i mean the ceo of
goldman sachs goes to davos and declares
he's not going to take a company public
unless it's board is sufficiently
diverse i think that is just a game to
deflect accountability and potential
consequence from a newly ascended
political left in america these these
are really i think a scammy kind of vote
capitalism completely inaudible all the
way down
that's not the entire story though and i
talk about the other nuances and
dimensions of this too there's woke
executives there's woke investors
there's also woke consumers and many of
whom are are themselves employees in
these firms too i think one of the
things i've seen in the publishing
industry somehow the ceos of these
publishers have mistaken their own
employees as being their top customers
that they're accountable to i don't
quite understand that model of
leadership reminds me of parents who vie
to be friends with their teenage kids
but putting that to one side as a model
of leadership i think there is a real
phenomenon here that i faced too by the
way i would say over company
you know nearly a thousand employees
many of them young many of them come
from top universities that we recruited
from for years and i detailed this in
one of the early chapters in the book in
the wake of george floyd's death were
frustrated with me as ceo for not saying
or doing enough to condemn systemic
racism in the united states rather than
doing what i thought we needed to be
doing which was developing medicines for
all people who needed them including
black
so
i'm really sympathetic to that challenge
it actually gets to the heart of what i
think is is
the real cultural solution that we need
to be grappling with not just as
americans but i think as members of
western liberal democracies more
thoroughly is that you brought up the
fact that we're all millennials okay
fine
you said you guys are millennials too as
defined on this on the
other side of this conversation is that
about right yeah yeah just about all
three of us count us in that bucket i
think we're part of a generation and
even a generation younger than us in gen
z
that's hungry for a cause we're hungry
for purpose
we're hungry for meaning we're hungry
for identity the same things human
beings have always hungered for for time
and memorial but we live in a moment
where the kinds of things that used to
fill that moral hunger
notions like faith
patriotism
hard work and identity built through
hard work have receded in our
consciousness but we're still human
beings and so we don't lose those
impulses we just relocate them to new
philosophies to new religions to
post-modernism to wokism instead without
recognizing that we're actually
submitting to just a new form of
religion that effectively becomes our
opium for the masses and you know i
think that many businesses then you
could argue are
doing what they need to do by servicing
millennial customers that demand that
okay we're hungry for a coswell we want
to go to ben and jerry's and order an
ice cream with some morality on the side
or we want to go to nike and buy a pair
of sneakers but buy a pair of sneakers
with shoelaces that come with a flourish
of social justice at the tips that's
what we sort of determine when we're
buying as consumers and i think the real
answer there isn't necessarily to
criticize the businesses who fulfill
that demand either in their consumer
base or to placate their employees
but to really take an aim at the culture
that makes the mistake that we can mix
morality with commercialism as our means
of satisfying our true moral hunger it's
like we're feeding our moral hunger with
the equivalent of fast food when in fact
the thing we're really hungry for is
more substantial fare and we got to this
farcical point where our politics
determines the sandwiches that we buy
and our sandwich makers have to pick
their politics when in fact what we
really need to recognize is that you
can't you can't solve morality the
problems of morality by just buying the
right kind of t-shirt you have to
grapple with the hard work of
understanding who we are as individuals
and as a people and how we're bound
together as a people across our diverse
attributes and characteristics that's
real hard cultural work that there's no
silver bullet for i offer the beginnings
of some reflections towards solutions in
the book but you're right that i think
that in many ways businesses are
responding to cultural conditions that
businesses as neutral actors take as
given and then try to hide the fact that
they're neutral actors by wearing the
guard of morality in the form of
post-modern progressivism but actually
what the essence of what's really going
on is a cultural change in our society
that is not just top down driven though
in some cases it is that's the goldman
sachs and the black rocks and the of the
world but there's also a bottom-up
change too that many other businesses in
the middle that are otherwise neutral
actors are really appearing to bend the
knee to and i think that we have to take
aim at that bottom of cultural change
that we need to drive that is is easier
said than done but i think it's the work
that we need to do
in fact i'm gonna to make this a little
of a little dark and and go deep because
i think you make such a profound point
uh about the lack of of of these
superior things that we used to fill our
lives with and we no longer do and so we
need a replacement one of the
consequences of that and i've heard you
talk about it in the past
is that you create two economies
and uh if if conservatives only buy
black rifle coffee and progressives only
by starbucks or whatever it is if that
spreads through society
then anyone with half a brain can see
that the long-term consequence of that
is the tearing of society apart because
the things that used to unite us the the
football games that you'd go to
irrespective of your politics well hey
if you're an nba fan like me you have to
make a conscious decision every time do
you want 20 minutes of social justice
shove down your throat before every game
or do you just watch something else
right
exactly i think once we have two nbas
and two two major league baseballs it's
the beginning of the end as we know it i
think it is the path to civil war and
and i don't say that lightly but i think
and we're not there yet but i think that
if we do get there i think that would be
a dangerous uh you know dangerous
harbinger of bad things to come if you
look at the us civil war civil wars in
other societies actually they begin
not just when you have a divided polity
that's existed for a lot of human
history
nations get through that when nations
don't get through that is when there's
no cultural cohesion to bind people
together across their divided politics
and and i worry that as the private
sector goes woke as it becomes
politicized we lose the necessary
apolitical spaces that bind us together
as one people regardless of whether
we're democrats or republicans
conservatives or liberals black or white
we require those spaces american
solidarity i think i think western
liberal solidarity as we know it
requires those spaces to bind us
together and i think that that cultural
fragility i think is one of the greatest
dangers of all as we become more fragile
when divisive politics infects otherwise
unifying activities like our places of
work the places we go to play sports the
places we go to listen to music once
those become politicized too the movie
theaters for that matter it is i think
the beginning of the end of western
liberalism and the project of western
liberalism as we know it and worst of
all
the people who are rooting for the end
of western liberalism in other parts of
the world and and you know i'm not shy
about naming names i'm going to put the
chinese communist party at the top of
that list
are exploiting that to drive their own
advantage and i'll tell you
a joke i i told recently
and you know i think it's meant in good
humor but i think at the heart of it is
i think a very dark turn in the story
where let's just say mao zedong comes
back to the chinese countryside in year
2021 and he sees a farmer on the
countryside and he has a conversation
with the farmer and he says okay well
farmer what happened to those food
shortages that we used to have when i
was ruling do we still have those food
shortages and the farmer says chairman
no we don't have those food shortages in
fact we have the opposite problem
we have too much food and our people are
are dying of diabetes today and so
chairman mao says very good very good
that's good to hear now what about our
steel production targets we were going
to produce more steel than the united
kingdom as part of our 50-year plan 50
years later have we now achieved that to
which the chinese farmer says oh no
forget about beating the united kingdom
as china one of our provinces alone
defeats the united kingdom in steel
production every year to which chairman
mao says that's very good to hear
but tell me what happened to that
chinese cultural revolution where we
were going to have that proletariat
uprising
whatever happened to that
to which the farmer laughs and says
chairman
we don't do that here anymore
we've outsourced that to the united
states and i say that
jokingly but i think that there's a
version of this in which the chinese
leadership
deeply understands the kinks in our
armor they have a
a word for western wokeness byzuo
literally refers to woke white people in
the united states and in other western
countries and they use it to laugh at us
but now they're using that progressive
front to actually co-opt companies that
criticize relentlessly the united states
over black lives matter or whatever he
brought the nba the nba is in this
category but they don't say a peep in
china in fact they supplicate to china
they like prostrate like lap dogs to
their ccp overlords while consistently
biting the united states in the process
and that creates a false moral
equivalence between chinese nihilism and
let's call it western idealism and i
think when you equate the two then
nihilism wins every time that's what
allows xi jinping when he's pressed on
your side of the pond by eu leaders on
the xinjiang human rights crisis with
the weakers right now the first thing xi
jinping says is that actually black
lives matter shows the united states is
no better which would be laughable if it
weren't for the fact that nike and
disney and the nba and blackrock and
every other major american corporation
that does business in china criticize
the united states without saying a peep
in china lends moral legitimacy to the
claims that they make and i actually
think that's probably the most dangerous
threat to democracy is not even the
philosophical one from within that i
described though i think that's a
problem but actually a dangerous one
backed up through not soft power but
hard power through the use of force as
exercised by the ccp over the course of
the next 10 years and you can mark my
words today the day that taiwan is
invaded by china nike and disney and the
nba are not going to say a peep they
might even praise them and implicitly
help them do it that's the state of the
world we live in is they've turned these
corporations into trojan horses where
western countries like the united states
and the united kingdom thought for 30
years that they could send big macs and
happy meals to china and somehow spread
democracy and instead autocratic nations
like china have turned that on its head
and instead of using our money on the
west to get them to be more like us
they've actually used their money to you
make us behave more like them and i'm
sorry to say that it is working in a way
that both progressives and conservatives
need to wake up to but even well-minded
progressives need to recognize that once
they've turned corporations into vectors
to drive social change those
corporations then become vehicles to bid
for someone else's agenda too and
nobody's mastered that game better than
the ccp it's actually my book is if i
may say the first book that i believe is
is laying out the geopolitical
implications of wokism and i think that
that's probably one of the most
illuminating parts of the book i i
thought for me in the process of writing
it but i hope for the readers who read
it as well
and one of the best examples of that was
the case of disney and the and the
uyghurs would you mind expanding into
that a little bit yeah look i mean i
mean disney yeah
my blood's already boiling i i
keep myself in check here but
disney says it could not film in the
united states a couple of years ago in
the state of georgia if georgia passed
the equivalent of a new abortion
restriction or whatever
yet last year they go to the shenzhen
province of china literally ground zero
of the uyghur human rights crisis over a
million uyghurs detained in
concentration camps subject to force
sterilization communist indoctrination
in what i view as some of the worst
human rights atrocities committed by a
major nation since the third reich of
germany and disney does not say a peep
until they get to the end of the film
and in the film's credits i'm not even
kidding you
they go out of their way to publicly
thank the local ccp authorities in the
xinjiang province for allowing the
privilege of filming there when in fact
those are some of the very authorities
responsible for enslaving the uyghurs
today so i i just think that that
two-faced behavior is
is you know really revealing about the
way in which much of the west
will supplicate to the guy who pays them
their last dollar or their last one as
you want as the k as the case may be top
gun is is a film coming out later this
year where tom cruise in the original
movie was a real maverick and he
actually had in one of the scenes a
jacket that had a number of of us allies
on his sleeve including the nation of
taiwan including japan
and in the revised version of the film
you'll see him wear his jacket coming
out this fall you won't see taiwan's
flag you won't see japan's flag and i'll
let you guess exactly why that is the
world we live in they have invaded the
movies we watch the universities our
kids are educated at the companies we
buy our products from there are trojan
horses from within and the battle of
troy was one not through the front door
but when actually one of the sides was
invaded by the other through the back
door with a trojan horse that they
accepted and the horse that were the
trojan horses today look every bit as
appealing as the trojan horses in the
battle of troy in the form of nike in
the form of disney in the form of the
nba the movies we watch the clothes we
wear the sports we play yet those trojan
horses are actually the vectors of
actually advancing the agenda of what i
view as the enemy and we have not seen
it happen in plain sight that's a big
part of what i'm laying out in the book
that being the case vivek how do we
fight back then against these
corporations how do we persuade the
ordinary person on the street because
there is a heartening example of this
when gillette did their uh toxic
masculinity advert when and their their
their share prices dropped massively as
a result because nobody wanted to buy
their products yeah look i think
sometimes sometimes consumer boycotts
could be a short-term answer i'm not a
big fan of that in the long run because
i think to take think that takes us back
on the path to two economies which then
puts us back on the pat back on the path
to civil war i'm not a big fan of that
approach though i'm sympathetic to those
who feel like they need to resort to
that as a mechanism to fight back
i think the right answer has to be
not to just cancel locism in return to
adopt ill liberal methods to fight
illiberalism i think it has to be to
dilute that agenda to irrelevance
by reviving a shared identity that runs
so deep
that it makes localism seem silly by
comparison i think that the right way to
fight racism by the way and this would
be my advice to the left would be the
same thing it's not to
get that last burning ember and go to
the person who might harbor one last
racist thought as you define it and yell
at them don't be racist i can tell you
the best way to throw kerosene on those
last burning embers is to try to cancel
something in reverse as opposed to
letting it atrophy to irrelevance as it
has over the last six decades my advice
to the right is the same in reverse is
the right way to fight woke-ism isn't to
try to cancel it or pummel it into
submission it is to dilute it to
irrelevance through civic education
through a revival of civic identity
through a revival of the kinds of things
that used to give us meaning and fill
that black hole of hunger for moral
meaning and purpose that's the hard work
that we do i'm sorry to interrupt but
it's an important point to interrupt
because you talk about educating the
next generation yeah
we've just had christopher roof on the
show talking about crt
you obviously educated at yale and
harvard i imagine you would agree with
me that the the overwhelming majority of
the faculty at america's elite colleges
and universities and likewise here in
the uk uh are quite sympathetic
or at least willing to tolerate wokeness
so
when we talk about that how is that
going to happen let me double click on
that for a second just yes the point
that i make in the book i think that
that's true i think it actually misses
even the bigger problem in the
universities which is a managerial
cancer so the ratio of administrators at
universities to professors has actually
rapidly grown like a cancer
universities around both the us and i
think the same is true in the united
kingdom though i haven't looked at the
same numbers in the same precision as i
have in the u.s what you see is these
administrators the associate deans the
diversity administrators are now
outstripping faculty by ratios like ten
to one and even when faculty or
conventional faculty lean left in an
environment that's not checked by sort
of an administrative state within the
university itself the equivalent of what
i call deep corporate in corporate
america it's sort of the deep state in
the university itself
they're able to at least engage in an
open marketplace of ideas i mean harvard
you know at the time i went there a
decade and a half ago was really a
different place than it is today where
yes conservatives may have been in the
intellectual minority but there was
still a marketplace of ideas where
people could debate in the open without
fear of reprisal but i think the
managerial cancer universe is actually a
much bigger problem is the growth of
people whose job it is to do to
administer a diversity equity and
inclusion agenda which in fact is
anything but the things that they mean
in the name of diversity they actually
mean no diversity of thought in the name
of inclusion they actually mean creating
an exclusionary culture where certain
points of view aren't welcome and the
problem with people who occupy those
seats is once once you give them a job
they want to permanently keep that job
keep getting a paycheck which by the way
contributes to the
increasing cost of higher education in
this country subsidizing these toxic
diversity administrators that reign
supreme at our universities that even
look down on and silence professors who
might be liberal but who even permit
contrary thought and so those professors
then bend the knee because they want to
be able to you know at least keep their
jobs without actually being
abused as many as some professors were
at yale just a couple of years ago for
making the controversial statement that
students should be able to make adult
choices in how they dress for halloween
they were pummeled with quasi violence
as a consequence and the administrators
stand by as the students do it so i
actually think the bigger problem the
universities is this managerial cancer
in the administrative class of the
university even beyond the professors
themselves now you're right now i think
the question actually begins with
primary education upstream of the
universities though to create and fill
that moral hunger for a new generation
because what's happened today is that
the wokeness used to be about
challenging the system
today there's no doubt about it wokeness
is the system it controls as an ideology
nearly every major institution that we
know about in the western world from
universities to non-profits to museums
to companies to government to military
now it's ubiquitous and i actually think
that creates an opportunity though on
the other side for a new generation
of kids who are turning 18 or turning 19
today
who want to be counter cultural it's
what you want to do when you're 19. you
want to stand up to the system you want
to be counter cultural you want to be
rebellious you want to be heteronox you
want to be a hippie that's part of what
made woken so attractive over the course
of the last couple of decades but today
now that woke-ism is the system there's
a new pitch for that new generation if
you want to stand up to the system
there's a new way to do it and i think
that meeting that demand and cultivating
that demand with the right kinds of
leaders who are able to set that
cultural tone of being heterodox through
actually thinking independently rather
than reciting the same slogans as your
peers that could create an opportunity
for new generation through civic
education that begins in primary
education that really creates i think
the conditions for a turn of the
pendulum in the opposite direction
culturally i think some of that's driven
first personally too i think great
leaders are going to have to step up the
the reagans and the thatchers of the
world you know they cured the 1970s i
think that we're gonna have to figure
out somebody who cures the people real
leaders who cure the diversity decade of
the 2010s that elevated in our
consciousness all of the ways in which
we're different and somehow celebrate
that
to revive the commonality that binds us
together as one people across those
skin-deep differences and i think that
you know from an american perspective
america is nothing if it is not bound
together across its diversity we can
celebrate our appearance of diversity
until we're blue in the face
we're nothing if we aren't bound across
that diversity by something greater or
else we're just a bunch of different
looking people occupying a common space
looking at our iphones and doing what
our smartphones tell us to do on a given
day that isn't what this country was
supposed to be we're supposed to be a
country built on idealism and a shared
set of ideals that bring together an
otherwise divided polyglot group of
people you know i think it takes it
takes leaders to be able to lead people
back to that vision of what binds them
together i think the conditions that
we've created create selective pressure
for those kinds of leaders to emerge i
think it's no no accident that reagan
came in the 80s after the doldrums of
the identity crisis that america and
similar countries faced under the
conditions of the 70s i view us as being
in somewhat of an analogous place here
now at the end of the 2010s and so it's
going to be a combination of factors
that drive the cultural change i do lay
out some policy proposals in the book
that i think can create the conditions
for that cultural change but even those
policies are really just a form of
symptomatic therapy and what i really
think we need is the beginnings of a
cultural cure
vivek aren't you worried that
it's gone too far now and particularly
with big tech
big tech is so powerful if you look back
at what happened over the pandemic the
reason that
blm came to public prominence was
because of social media because we were
all physically locked in our homes we
couldn't go anywhere there were billions
of eyeballs on a screen
do you not worry that we've we're simply
too far down the road now i don't think
we're too far down there i think we're
getting close though i mean if you look
at big tech look at who the biggest
beneficiaries of the pandemic were was
of course big tech stock prices are
through the roof guess who actually
censored any content on the internet
about anti-lockdown speech facebook
youtube you could post about anti-lock
this is one of the most important public
policy questions of our time whether or
not to lock down an economy and there's
many ways to fight the pandemic you
could debate mass you'd make vaccines
you could do it social distancing but
lockdowns talking about economic
lockdowns of businesses in retrospect it
doesn't even look like a particularly
good way of having fought the
coronavirus
yet debates were censored by the likes
of youtube by the likes of facebook and
yet they were the biggest beneficiaries
of all so i i think that big tech and
china represent the two defining threats
to western liberal democracies as we
know it and and i you know i i don't
think it's i don't think potential
question i don't think we're past the
point of no return yet
but if the kids who are in first grade
now graduate from 12th grade before we
fix the problem then i think we lose an
entire generation and i don't think we
have a generation left before the
existence of not only america but but
sort of the western liberal democracy
and western liberal edifice as we know
it is brittle enough to withstand
the loss of an entire generation in
between so i think that's kind of the
the clock we're working with is within
the 2020s we need to have fixed this or
else we will have done permanent
irreparable damage and that's a big part
of why i'm writing it's a big part of
why you know i stepped aside a ceo to
make a move that i wouldn't imagine
myself making a couple of years ago to
be able to be among the voices that i
think are going to be needed to to drive
change that's part of why i wrote the
book but i think laying eyes on this
problem i'm optimistic will allow i
think the right kinds of people amongst
our everyday citizenry to galvanize to
create a new cultural response a
cultural revival that i think renders
this this you know post-modernism of the
last decade irrelevant by comparison and
you know i know we're running towards
the end of time here but i just want to
say thank you for having me and being
able to have this conversation not just
here in the american context but but
across the pond with all of you i think
is every bit as as important you know i
think that uh you know i think that
there's a deep relationship between
between our two countries in a way that
you know i think allows the ideas that
reverberate on one side that that sort
of echo on one side to reverberate on
the other so that's why we hope we hope
you sort your [ __ ] out because we keep
importing it and this is what we end up
with here uh uh we've we've got a little
bit of time uh go for it yeah
the question that
i want to ask is this and i think it's a
key question and libertarians don't like
it and people on the right don't like it
but divide decisive action is needed
isn't part of the problem like i said
before big tech they're too big they're
too powerful don't we need the
government to go in and again i know the
right and the libertarians they get
their panties in the twister actually
there's a lot of people on the right now
who are calling for people to break up
the companies but anyway but yeah but
just to break up the companies
so so i'm not a big breakups guy i
understand the impulse i'm sympathetic
to it i certainly don't want to live in
a world where the biggest technology
companies in the world are chinese
rather than american because that's
going to be a very different kind of
problem than the one we're grappling
with today and as i said earlier i'll
keep saying it again two biggest threats
to the western liberal edifice china and
big tech in that order now i think that
that's one reason not to i think the
other reason not to is look i think that
i think that there's a better version
that we had lived even in the 1990s the
original promise of a free and open
internet when google was supposed to
represent it as opposed to the perverted
thing it's become today you know i think
that there's a better way forward than
breaking it up and also by the way i
don't think breaking it up solves the
problem because the real problem in
silicon valley today isn't a monopoly on
products it isn't the idea that they're
somehow using this to gouge price like
the rockefellers or carnegies or
vanderbilts might have done in monopoly
eras in the past
they're actually making many of their
products available for free consumer
choice is widespread the real problem is
different
it's a monopoly on ideas it is an
ideological cartel and i can tell you
from firsthand experience talking to
venture capitalists in silicon valley
having raised money from some of them
being actually in the context of smaller
startups
all of them many of them at least bend
the knee to that same ideology so if you
take four big companies and break it up
to 40 small companies but they all still
subject themselves to the same ideology
you still have an ideological cartel
rather than an ideological monopoly but
i'm not sure we're that much better off
in the marketplace of ideas so both from
an efficacy perspective and from a risk
avoidance perspective if you will on the
chinese risk and on the risk side and on
the on the efficacy side i don't know
that we're actually going to solve the
problem of the monopoly of ideas we're
not going to if we've got to change our
culture
breaking up big tech isn't going to do
it i'm not a big breakups guy i do think
though that we do need real action
one of the actions in the united states
that we need to take is to teach these
companies that you can't have it both
ways either you operate as an actual
private company and you get the special
benefits of being a private company or
we recognize a big part of what these
companies are doing today which is to
act as an agent of the state to do
through the back door what government
can't directly do through the front door
they're working hand in glove with
government to censor free speech and
open debate that the government doesn't
want to see online but the government
technically can't censor so it's using
their censorship bureau and silicon
valley to do it and by the way give them
special legal immunity in the form of
section 230 protection which is a
statutory protection available to
technology companies in the united
states that i won't go into here
i say you can't have it both ways either
you operate as a private company and you
get treated as a private company or you
operate in coordination with the
government with special government
privileges but then you come and operate
according to the same constraints as the
government including in the u.s the
first amendment to the constitution of
the united states which protects free
speech you can't have it both ways i
also say by the way that if we live in a
world where you can't discriminate at
least in the american context on the
base of race or gender or sexual
orientation or religion or national
origin which is the case in the us today
then you shouldn't be able to you should
you should not be able to discriminate
on the basis of political belief or
political expression either if race
gender sexual orientation and national
origin are protected classes then so
should political belief and political
expression be too so those are some of
the bolder solutions that actually
libertarians won't like but nonetheless
i sort of apply in the book to say that
you can't have it both ways we need
even-handed applications of policy
well that makes sense but again again
the question for me if you don't mind is
who are you going to elect to do that
right because some of those changes will
require elected officials uh so uh
you know we you
you had donald trump he didn't do
anything about it right yeah he he
started a conversation he didn't really
finish the work that needed to be done
look i think the next as i said the next
decade is really important reagan was
born out of necessity on the back of the
70s but i think and decades like the one
we've been through create the conditions
for selective pressure that hopefully
create generational leaders that are
able to drive that change and so i'm
hopeful for what we would what we will
see in the next decade but if we're in
the 70s without reagan i think we're in
a tough spot so i think that the
emergence of real political leadership
and not just one among 450 congressmen
or one among 100 senators but but really
starting at the top and not just at the
white house but governors at every state
level and even at local levels need to
need to step up to be able to drive real
change as executives not just as not
just as legislators
you address that
and defend yourself as a true american
uh very quickly before we let you go
we've got one final question and we'll
do a couple of questions for locals and
the final question is always what's the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
hmm
yeah look i think that
i think we should talk about the way in
which our cultural fragility at home
begets fragility abroad i i just think
about i look at what happened in
afghanistan in recent weeks in the us's
disastrous exit from afghanistan is that
deeply related to or is it not related
to the kinds of issues we've talked
about here actually they're deeply
related i think there's exactly one way
that president biden could have deterred
the taliban from doing what they did
which was to issue a credible threat of
total decimation and annihilation if
they came anywhere near kabul he didn't
do that but the reason he didn't do it
is that even if he did do it they would
have never believed it because he lacked
the moral standing
to use extraordinary force precisely
when we needed it most because he's
obsessed with self-criticism and that's
part of what the woke ideology does is
it undermines moral fortitude from
within and i think one of the things we
need to understand as we head into this
brave new world of the new decade ahead
is to recognize that cultural fragility
at home
begets fragility abroad and i think that
in some ways it's counterintuitive that
we will see
more the rise of the thing that we none
of us want to see which is the rise of
evil on the global stage the weaker we
are at home both in places like the
united states and the united kingdom and
i think that's something we need to be
talking more about is the relationship
between fragility at home and the rise
of fragility abroad
vivek it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on the show
if people want to find you online
where's the best place to do that you
can find me on social media i
reluctantly joined twitter a year ago i
wasn't on social media for years
but starting last year ahead of ahead of
publishing the book i'm back on social
media
vivekramaswamy.com is my website you can
you can check out some of my work and uh
and get the book there as well and most
importantly read the book i'm not doing
this as a commercial endeavor i'm doing
this to get the message out but i hope
that it starts a conversation that we
need to be having in every segment of
our society
it's a brilliant book we thoroughly
recommend everybody read it of course we
do we'll ask you a couple of questions
for our locals uh but for the moment
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you guys for watching and
listening at home we'll see you very
soon with another brilliant interview
like this one and they always go out
wednesdays and sunday 7 p.m uk time 2
p.m eastern standard and tuesdays
thursdays fridays and saturdays are our
raw shows at the same time take care and
see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode and if you believe that the work
we do here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below